I was the queen of the boardroom now
I'll be the queen of the Big Brother
house Omarosa sounds tough but she might
to be softer than we think it should we
be right
don't say that yes the apprentice of
villain broke down in the Celebrity Big
Brother backyard the human side of you
know celebrities the emotional moment
happened after fellow houseguests Ross
Matthews asked her about her time
working for President Donald Trump in
Washington I never got it why you went
to the White House with him I felt like
it was like a call to duty I felt like I
was serving my country not serving him
like I was haunted by tweets every
single day like what is equal to tweet
next does anybody say to him what are
you doing I had tried to be that person
and then all the people around him it
had to be it's interesting to see Ross
and Omarosa bonding cuz he told DT she
was the one person he did not want to
see when he walked into that house I
mean anybody that would bring a
necessary negative drama I mama Rosa
there are certain people I don't want to
be there
[Music]
you